TAKAIKO AIKAWA: So on campus,
besides our language classes,
our students have
some opportunities
to interact with native
Japanese speakers,
or so we have lots of events.
One major event is lunch table.
That is actually sponsored
by MIT Japan, which actually
is a program that sends
a lot of our students
to Japan as internship.
So together with
MIT Japan program,
we host a Japanese
lunch table once a week,
so that students go to
lunch table and then
the native speakers of Japanese,
especially the Japanese Wives
Club at MIT, they really
support this activity.
We also have a
Japan at MIT event.
This event is also in
collaboration with MIT Japan.
And at the beginning
of each semester,
we kind of have a big
party, together with sushi,
and then we introduce
language program.
At the same time, we introduce
a lot of Japan-related culture
courses.
And then we invite
Japanese Wives
Club so that students
can be exposed
to cultural activities,
such as tea ceremony
or how to wear kimono,
those kind of things.